while in-person music halted when the
pandemic hit
musicians and their students found a
workaround going virtual
today we introduce you to musician josh
crooks who has performed across the
southwestern us as a solo guitarist
and in larger ensembles as well
[Music]
i was one of the first teachers i know
locally to kind of pivot towards
virtual lessons josh crooks has been
teaching music privately for more than a
decade
while there was certainly no playbook
for virtual lessons
he found his students could focus even
better at times yeah it's definitely a
different
uh approach for sure there's not much of
a
hey put your finger here or let me fix
that for you anymore you have to come
about it from a
a little bit more of a theoretical
standpoint
i think and less show me show me and
more of
tell me josh first picked up a guitar at
age 12.
a sports scholarship brought him to unlv
but he switched paths learned how to
become a classically trained musician on
guitar
and got his degree his main wheelhouse
genre is spanish guitar
but while bookings at area resorts and
venues came to a halt
he's kept busy with his virtual lessons
and performing at
outdoor weddings i've been trying to do
as much as i can to just
dive into the music world from all
angles he prefers to stay positive about
the year 2020 saying the lockdown gave
him the opportunity to teach more people
i've also had some adults that maybe
used to play in their youth
and now that maybe they found themselves
a little bit more free time
from age 5 to 80 he's managed to connect
with a variety of students
all over the country i've taught lessons
during the pandemic and
to students in new york state oregon
arizona
so it's been really fun to expand the
reach he
is very talented he also opened an
online musical instrument store at
woodvibrationsmusic.com
he says the silver lining is that all
things are possible
you just have to find more than just one
way to do it and with music he says
there's no age limit you can play and
learn your entire life
very true